hi everyone it's Jerry I have a seek out
for five minute game on chess cube okay
we have a game against a 23 42 so let's
try let's try efore see what black is
gonna do
okay Sicilian I guess we'll go for an
open Sicilian mmm
the best cough possibly or maybe even a
dragon with g6 accelerated dragon okay
so black is reserving the option with
their EEP on maybe e6 maybe e5 and I'm
thinking e5 is going to be played going
for that variation Sebastian akov
Sicilian so I'm I'm D 6 D 6 gets played
and my night on b5 is going to be kicked
around so I'll just wait to first react
to that elbow and and I have seen this
a4 move played before you know typically
there's this Bishop g5 line and then a 6
kicks my knight to a 3 and then b5 gets
played so I'm wondering if I should just
try maybe a 4 in this position just to
try something different I'm gonna go
with that I've played this many times as
white Bishop g5 but a 4 certainly going
to be a little bit offbeat I don't know
how good it is but maybe a black will be
out of a book ok so maybe I can still
just go forward with Bishop g5 I think
it's still going to be important to
eliminate the knight on f6 because he's
a good defender of the d5 square and in
fact as a result of that earlier a5 move
let's react to that as a result of the
earlier e5 move that's a directory a
direct consequence of the e5 is the
weakened d5 square so I could snap I
could take that night out at any moment
I don't know if right now is best
however and in fact as a result of a 4 I
could now maybe play Knight c4 to e3 and
train my pieces on that
d5 square so that's what I'm going to do
I think actually wait a second
my therby tactics in the form of Knight
c4 because my bishop on g5 is
unprotected
so is there maybe a knight takes on e4
or something hmm
if Knight c4 is there Knight takes e4
here that c4 Knight takes e4 Bishop
takes Bishop Knight takes Knight we're
both on each other's Queens and they'll
take the knight um maybe I'm just seeing
a ghost here alright so well actually no
this is this is quite strong I was
thinking Knight c4 could be maybe met
with Bishop g5 but uh I was hitting that
d6 pawn so okay maybe I should be
developing my pieces now alright so
let's go with Bishop here so my knight
on c4 could go to e3 if Bishop e6 just
93 I don't know if maybe a five would
have been I moved that I should have
been playing let's just work on where I
have an advantage and that is my d5
square so I've been able to position my
Knights pretty well I think Bishop g5
just to try and get rid of my III Knight
is gonna be pretty good so let's just
castle a5 is something maybe I should
have been doing a5 lending a support
point for my knight because I could
anticipate a knight d5 and I think I
want to go with this one because how do
I get rid of this knight on d4 however
and this is a big however which Knight
do I play to that d5 square I don't know
if I want to allow black to give up
their dark square Bishop so I might be
more inclined to go this route yeah I'm
gonna go with this am I missing anything
now I'm gonna go here falled and I'm
trying to get a 5 in pivot my knight on
B 6 can get my other night
- this d5 square I want to avoid
the dark square bishop from giving
itself up for my night so I'm in a pivot
point now on b6 there is pressure
against c2 so this is going to be a
little bit annoying here however my
night on b6 is also going to be pretty
annoying isn't it
Knight b6 get my other Knight to d5
that's pretty much where all my
attention is focused am I wrong to be
that that focused on the d5 square I
don't think so this is really my only
the blacks only weekend point and so I
have to play where there are weaknesses
in my opponent's position I think
although I guess f5 is coming up but now
if we could trade light square bishop so
I think I'm doing quite well so I'm just
moving that night so this other one can
start to contribute I look to follow up
with c3 I have to be very cautious
actually because this that Bishop
controlling a lot of dark squares whoa
that move scares me that's my first
thought is I am scared with that move ok
do I should I really be scared though ok
my pawn isn't a pin and Bishop h3 is
threatened so yeah I should definitely
be scared
so King h1 I don't like to have to do
that but I think it's necessary it's
getting a little bit scary there's
there's the bishop Knight Queen and
Bishop in close proximity to my King and
I have a piece this guy right here isn't
going to be coming over here anytime
soon to trying to defend and okay it's a
good thing I took a peek at my clock 138
- okay down a minute and my knight okay
if I could get a Knight to d5 then I'm
threatening some checks whoa
Queen trade okay what do I do
Queen trade oh okay wait let's go with
let's go with this right away yeah
Knight here okay I'm threatening a fork
if Queen takes I think it's important to
capture with this rook
why why that rook or maybe not mmm I
don't know I almost just primo
accidentally there Queen takes Queen if
I do rook F takes Queen then there might
be nice c2 and he's on my a one ruck I
want to be able to get in Knight d7 but
at the same time if I end up kicking the
knight eventually to on c3 then Knight
b3 could be problematic so okay blacks
defending against that now I think I go
forward with c3 right away yeah c3 right
away yeah missing anything I don't think
so okay got a minute left
the Knight has to run somewhere and ooh
that's a no that's not a blunder I'm
losing my light squared bishop or am i I
don't want to give up my light square
bishop Queen takes Knight Queen takes
bishop is that Queen going to get
trapped I like I like my light square
bishop I don't want to give that up okay
rook to a3 if Bishop takes Queen rook a3
I got to watch over my a5 pond okay
Bishop c5 Bishop C to think bishop C to
MIT Bishop C to no matter what and
actually be floors maybe coming up to
kick that night around again I got to
get this Bishop out of here from d2 and
okay let's go go go go go all right Oh
what am i doing that's a blunder I meant
to do Bishop C - oh I got move confusion
right there oh that's horrible
is there any resistance I can't even get
the piece back oh that's awful well I'm
gonna I'm gonna keep it I'm resigning I
was just saying Bishop c2 and then I
went with a different move ah
let me go back over this quickly very
quickly I'm very very upset with myself
right now ah okay so let me just point
this out right here so there is the
Bishop a4 right here is a little bit mmm
I don't know how well known it is but
Bishop g5 is certainly more typical a4
is to prevent the a6 and b5 expansion
but you know is it is it going to be
worth the time I think you know I I can
certainly see myself playing this
position out again hopefully without
making that serious blunder oh ok Bishop
d3 so the knight the Knights of the
regrouping I think I think this was a
pretty good idea to just focus and focus
on the d5 square and then Bishop g5 ok
yeah I want to avoid the dark square
Bishop exchange and then reposition my
pieces I'm doing that knight move so I
could get Knight d5 and followed by C 3
kicking that d4 Knight away so I have to
have to prevent Bishop Age 3 and then
just Knight there right away and then
this ugly blunder coming up Queen takes
Knight or Queen takes Queen in this
position I didn't like giving up my you
see it one of the reasons why I didn't
go for Queen takes Knight is because
after Queen takes Queen I'm in that I'm
in an awkward pin my queen is being my
knight on d5 would be pinned to my queen
so look there and I don't even want I
was just saying this I was just saying
Bishop c2 and then I wanted to follow up
with b4 has that ever happened to you
where you've switched the move order and
you ended up blundering well certainly
it has just happened to me and you have
seen it first okay that's all for this
video as always I hope you're able to
take something away from it even though
that was a really really ugly
okay take care bye